hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leaves this week on winners on a
wednesday i've got with me jay hey
and honestly this guy is absolutely
killing it in property he came on the
crash course
december last year december uh did some
further advanced training in the summer
now he's full time in property making a
full-time living doing lots of deals so
jay welcome to winners on the wednesday
thank you so much
i appreciate being here you know and
yeah it's it's great to be here
yeah honestly you know i knew you were
going to be successful we did some
coaching together
and i said you're going to be successful
you're going to be on winners wednesday
big energy means
big bank yes come on let's go and you're
right you're right about that yeah
you've done that so
talk me a little bit through what's
happened over the last few months
because you came on
the lease option boot camp yeah and on
top of that did four weeks of coaching
training mentoring
myself the team we got to know each
other and things just
changed yeah i mean i mean ultimately i
did a crash course in december
and then i began to do some cold
sourcing so i
had an investor work with a database and
um source one hmo deal but the problem
is that
culvert came along and conveyancing
absolutely stopped
and so no funds came through from that
deal
and so i found myself you know in
lockdown
with a baby a newborn baby in march
needing to sort of kind of pivot so
i thought let me take your lease options
uh boot camp in essence
to allow me to like sort some lease
option deals a lot of people said
you know lease options but you don't
know
it unless you're actually doing it right
yeah and so
uh did that lose lease options you mean
people trying to put you off going on
further training
yeah what by saying you don't need to do
that you can learn it all for
free exactly yeah right yeah but people
that sit on these chairs
the winners don't tend to say that
that's what the losers say
yeah i mean i think i think ultimately
uh
you have to get around where there's
great energy you know and i really
thought okay this is four weeks of
lockdown training baby like just
yeah you know four weeks and what did
that four weeks look like because
for anyone that's like thinking what you
know i sold on a webinar
yep and i said look you're gonna get
four weeks of coaching training
mentoring calls with me once a week
you're going to get the access to a load
of training what happened in that form
what did that four weeks look like
so what was great is that we got the
content up front
uh and then also there was like four um
weekly webinars i think it was on a
monday night you know so it's also a
great way to start the week in essence
and i think the key was to take massive
action
like in between the calls to really get
the most out of it because
i think if you get information that's
one thing but no one
learns how to ride the bike from just
reading how to ride the bike
correct you've got to try or or driving
a car you can't say
just read the theory book and you can
you got to get in the car with an
instructor
exactly and that's what you did yeah and
so i started to take action i did a
14-day lease options
challenge with with grum i think you
know graham right yeah i know yeah
young guy good good guy yeah good guy
and that propelled
um the whole sort of kind of prospecting
yeah like sort of kind of getting
gumtree links and sort of kind of you
know getting the names picking up the
phones and things like like this calling
agents
calling landlords i didn't secure
a lease option deal but it was
ultimately the skill
of prospecting speaker with landlords
speaking with agents
i became very comfortable with yeah and
then i think
lease options not completely easy but
the step before lease option is a rent
to rent correct yeah
because with a rent to rent you're not
worried about the sort of kind of
uh with the option to buy or setting the
price it's just
guaranteed rent and if that solves the
landlord's problem
we're in business ultimately and and you
can get the win-win with
the investor making 600 700 800 pounds
landlord getting 1 200 guaranteed rent
yeah everyone's happy so so that was the
process
uh from that june training to just sort
of kind of
push on so prior to june you've done the
crash course
you knew all about property because you
hadn't done any advanced training
coaching you actually weren't making any
money
exactly but then from june now you're
talking to agents
you're talking and connecting with
people that are successful not just me
but also
other like-minded people that are doing
property now it starts becoming real so
talk to me about your very first deal
that you did at your very first
time you made some money well um
literally i jumped onto spareroom.com
um and it was the fifth landlord i spoke
to actually
uh he lived in london and ultimately he
had
had a property a five bedroom in
coventry
culver times he wasn't asked to come up
and down to like check the property
so we agreed a guaranteed rent of 1250
for a five bedroom in coventry
it would make the investor 700 and and i
had um
a cold source that i was working with um
and that deal sold ultimately because
you know there was an investor that
wanted
let me ask you a question aj why would
you sell
a rental rent that's going to be making
700 pounds
cash flow a month why would you sell it
and not keep it for yourself
well i think at a certain point
i want to sort of kind of become
proficient at deal sourcing
i want to become the number one deal
source deal sourcing machine
yeah and so as ultimately i want to
learn that school and get deep into the
skill of sourcing
also have a bit of income coming in as
well and then
the next step is to you know take on
some of these properties because i've
seen it
where people they've started outsourcing
them for it's hard to sell this deal
yeah let me take this rent to rent on or
let me take this essay on and then
the sourcing journey takes the back seat
and so i'm kind of um unequivocally
focused
on becoming a great saucer and i guess
as well that makes sense
um the reason people can't sell the
deals by the way is because they don't
know how to close
yeah that's why um which you do which is
great but i think the thing is as well
rental rents
is usually there is some money involved
isn't there you've got you've got to
furnish it you've got a
and and right now you're full-time in
property you've got a little baby yeah
and it's there's fast pand and then the
slow pound and you're just
one fast pound yeah i mean i think i
think ultimately it's like a gps
for example you need to know where you
are i need income coming in
you know ultimately you need you need to
know where you're going and so
if it's like three four five k a month
i know where i am i'm not earning there
and nowhere i need to go
but the gps gives you roots now one
route might be for me to try and do hmos
but that takes too long
one route might be going on youtube
videos
that takes too long but another route
might be to take some advanced training
learn how to do lease options and rent
to rent
start connecting with people the gps
always gives you
multiple routes but you got to choose
the route that will be the
most efficient yeah fastest and and also
that will avoid some of the traffic and
speed bumps
that are going to be in any
entrepreneur's journey
you know so i think it's definitely
about taking the right route at the
right time and then
bigger things come along yeah and and
since then you did that first deal
you've been selling lots of deals yeah
um you've
i mean over the last two three months
yes what's happened
yeah so sold seven deals yeah good um
a 16k in total revenue 8k for me because
i've been cold sourcing
um and i really love the fact that
property is about interdependence
stephen covey talks about in terms of
his seven habits that
you know you have the stage of
independence i could do this by myself
yeah let me
youtube that and then interdependence
and i think in property
interdependence for me i love it because
if someone can make
1 500 and i can make 1 500 for a deal
we're both gonna work hard to sort of
kind of get that do over the line
you know rather than it being okay only
i win from the scenario so if it's like
both parties winning
yeah we share energy we share the fee
we share experience we share the joy we
share some of the pain
yeah as well you know so i think share
the experience
much more powerful than simply just
relying on
let me do this by myself i agree there's
a saying that says if you want to go
fast go alone yeah but if you want to go
far i go together
and if you look at people that are
winning in property the ones that
are selfish and try make all the money
and do it on their own and they you know
refuse to go on any training because
they're
they're tight and they're just no no and
it's all about themselves now and
what happens is after six twelve months
they've burned out yeah they're nobodies
they're finished and the people that
said actually i'm not gonna be greedy
i'm in this for the long game i'm gonna
invest in myself i'm gonna network i'm
gonna collaborate i'm gonna
give value to the community they're the
people that because because what goes
around comes around and when you when
you it's like the difference between
farming and hunting a farmer will plant
seeds
and white for growth a hunter will be
like what can i quit deal quick
you know and then they've got to go
hunting every time they get hungry
whereas a farmer just goes oh i'll just
pull
it's all there so i think what you've
done is you've really you're really um
working you've made some money which is
great you've done seven deals you've
been selling them on average for a few
grand and you've been getting
50 but now you're really stepping into
doing bigger stuff talk to them a bit
about
social housing because that's really
your thing now isn't it yeah that's what
you've been working on a lot the last
few weeks yes
so ultimately there's going on spare
room yeah which is good
but it can be time intensive and so um
in terms of marketing i've started to do
like you sort of kind of recommended
like the landlord letters right
and so i sent out 250 landlord letters
in coventry
and in the letters i put in a cup of tea
like a sachet of tea and and i said
you know have a cuppa on me and that's
what i found was like a nice sort of
kind of connection
with some of the landlords who says you
know i just enjoyed my
my cup of tea but as a result of 250
letters
i've got access to two portfolios and
also you know other like two or three
other sort of kind of properties but
what the push is now is selling
portfolios
okay yeah uh to social housing providers
which is a push now because there's a
big demand for
uh housing providers for people who are
homeless
um need care and so some of these
organizations they
um they need accommodation they need
portfolios
and so in fact today i've got you know
one or two meetings after
after this with some social housing
providers to see if we can match
the portfolios with um
the actual social housing provider and
see how it goes yes yes so what you're
going to
charge a middle fee yeah so i'll charge
per property in terms of a fee
but whereas before potentially i was
like looking okay let me try and find an
individual investor
who wants this unit now we're talking
about organizations who want properties
in bulk and so that's come about really
by accident by simply doing the
marketing
having landlords die
directly and so in essence it's just
finding another
another investor rather than an
individual investor
an organization which is um yeah which
is another angle
i think it's really smart and i think
that as well housing associations will
probably be much less
fussy about the fee if they want it
they'll just pay your fee you know
whereas
investors might be trying to i don't
ever want to pay i'm not sure whereas
the housing association will just say
does it tick the boxes is it what i want
and if you can then find it
i guess it's scalability as well yeah
because i think
i look at where people are thinking why
are they going to pay you well
in essence before the crash course i
didn't know how to work at roi
or i didn't know what landlord letters
were i did not have to find a portfolio
i've had to go intense into this i've
had to invest into this
ultimately so i've got to value my skill
and so ultimately if you find other
people that value this skill
and are willing to pay for it then
ultimately
why not sort of kind of have different
avenues so
you know potentially i will be still
cold-sourcing
but also there'll be bigger projects as
well yeah
talk to me jay about your background
prior to property because you're a
teacher
and you've got a you're also a rapper
i'm a rapper yes
yeah so we need to do a music video we
will we
so talk to me a little bit about your
background and really what made you want
to get into property in the first place
yeah so i've been teaching for the past
10 years now
i started when i was 10 years old um
ultimately what happened
is that i tried a bit of network
marketing
a bit of forex um a bit of social media
marketing agencies and
they didn't quite click and potentially
i know why they didn't click because
i love people you know i've loved coming
down today
you know to speak with you i love
connecting with people
and so you know when i start i always
thought property was a bit boring
potentially a bit too complicated
but that's why when i started the
journey and i came to the crash course
it was
a real immersion into doing
yeah yeah calling like jumping on stage
and sort of kind of
presenting a deal uh to people i
remember you on stage actually yeah
yeah you were one of the and there was a
lot of people how many people were that
event
uh was it two thousand or like yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it was at least a thousand people
there and you were on stage
pitching a deal all done properly i told
you to go up on stage
pitching a deal i mean what a crazy what
a crazy experience that was
yeah but like you know like when
something is the catalyst
to say okay let me let me stay in the
field because
because there's a saying how long are
you staying in the field it's like okay
are you going to the crash calls and
then
forgetting about it yeah you know or you
know are you doing the crash course and
say okay
sourcing stuff and making connections
finding investors
like if there's another opportunity to
do another training you know taking that
um so i think staying in the field after
the crash course
um sourcing a hmo property in stock on
trent
in january actually january the third i
saw that
it keeps you going and although i didn't
get one single penny
uh for six months i had
something to live for i knew that there
was a hmo deal outsourced
that gave me confidence you know i knew
okay
four weeks with yourself to like push me
forward
so there was something to stay in the
field for and i think you have to keep
that proximity like you told me
proximity is power yeah
you've got to stay in that proximity
otherwise what happens
you just get rolled back into it sure
environment
is is everything yeah who you who you
hang around with is who you become
yeah so so what point did you go full
time into property then how did that
happen
here it is so i got married last year
yeah congratulations but i'm like
married and then a kid
yeah yeah and so i thought i'd give
myself a little sabbatical okay
in essence uh but you know how it is
when
it's like nothing seems to stick no
money's coming into the bank account
and so actually i applied for a job in
march and
i got the job but something happened
what was the job
a teaching job okay something happened a
couple of weeks later
they withdrew that job offer like they
said something along the lines of
my references weren't satisfactory or
they said something
along those lines and then
thinking think and grow rich talks about
success consciousness
so you can have a situation like that
and you can sort of kind of let that
sort of kind of stop you or you can say
okay i'm gonna apply for five or six
other jobs
or you're gonna say let me just sort of
kind of
stay in property for a bit longer that
must have been really disheartening
though
it was it was because now you've you've
been you've you've been on a sabbatical
you've not been working for a few months
and now you think right i need some
money now
applying for a job being turned down at
the last minute
that's quite a rough place having
dependables now on you
is your wife working no so rough place
yeah money in the bank
uh no rough yeah but i think
and then i took a grand off yeah yeah
but this is where identity comes into it
is your identity more teacher
or entrepreneur yeah when you start
turning into an entrepreneur it's like
okay
let me try and solve this problem let me
try and find a way around it
but if the teacher is more part of you
it's like okay let me just
ah this stuff doesn't work samuel lee's
eye
he took my grand i didn't get a lease
option
yeah let me go on to the blogs samuel
lee's is a scammer
yeah yeah but people that do that though
they're just failure failures
you know they're people that if if you
see someone posting like that it just
means oh you failed
okay yeah that's it yeah there's nothing
else to do i think people don't realize
pareto's principle like with anything
it's always going to be any training
20 samuel leads 80 meme
80 me yeah not the other way around yeah
because because ultimately you know you
can't do my press-ups for me
yeah you can't pick up the phone for me
so it's taken what
i can do is i can give you everything
the process and to give you all the
steps map it out encourage you
yeah yeah but both parties have to do
yeah what they have to do right yeah
so you do the education look i'm a
teacher and
i saw what you were doing in that crash
course perfect
group work interaction people going
upstairs to not do their calls
moving around interactive rather than
just
zombie yeah you know you you need high
energy
yeah to retain stuff ultimately yeah and
so
it's all identity so i think if it's if
you really are
this entrepreneur and you sort of kind
of get that identity by
doing your affirmations taking in
positive information
your support circle then you're gonna
then your actions will reflect that
right like like
you become in shape you have to have
some sort of
identity switch right yeah to which you
okay you know now
like leave those sausages and pie and
mesh i'm gonna start eating properly i'm
gonna start running so you have to form
an identity and then after that
the actions are byproducts yeah so true
that's so true
and i think that it just shows the
importance of the knowledge for sure
but also the identity change you've got
you've got to believe
that it's possible i'm a winner it's
happening
because if you don't if you go onto a
training course thinking
is this a scam that's the wrong
mentality you need to say
i'm a property investor and i'm going to
win
and i need to get my first few deals in
the next few months and i'm going to get
helped by this training company and this
is going to happen
and then it will yeah but in your
situation you know
you're married you had a new baby you
had no money you've been turned down
on a job and i'm down there saying
you need to pay for education buddy and
and and that's
a bit of a responsibility on me because
if you hadn't
succeeded then now i'm thinking i took
his last grand
but but but i'm thinking no because i
believe i believe in people
i believed you were going to succeed you
succeeded and unfortunately i don't have
100
success rate but um you know i believe i
have
more success students than any other
training company on the planet yeah and
i'm super pumped and proud of what
you've done
it must feel good right now no it does
it does i mean i think
with with success it's not owned the
rent is due
every single month every single day and
so you you have to continually prospect
and
i realize prospecting is everything you
gotta continually
meet new investors continually get get
new deals in
to keep your business afloat otherwise
you know it's feast and famine
but but for sure you know being in this
very room
um you know working with you um pav
is here as well sort of kind of filming
this it's it's amazing to sort of kind
of
show what hard work and focus can do you
know
it's also interesting you say about
lease options being similar to rent to
rents
and then deals sourcing which is another
strategy altogether but they're all kind
of linked
hmos social housing all the different
strategies and presumably
when you start making more and more
money you're gonna then invest that into
some maybe brr deals development
and it all links so um yeah i think i
think ultimately it's just
we have to understand that it's a people
game yeah and
if you're able to solve people's
problems yes then
it doesn't matter whether it's br you
know buy to let hmo
developments you're solving people's
problems people say to me what's your
strategy samuel
i don't have a strategy i i'm a property
problem solver
i have different strategies up my sleeve
and i'll just say to people how can i
help and depending on their situation
the investor the owner the developer the
agent i'll take out whichever strategy
is appropriate and offer it to them and
i think that's the key
of a professional seasoned investor that
can help a lot of people
make a lot of money yeah yeah for sure
like i'm currently working with
with a landlord who has a portfolio you
know i'm saying okay you know
we could get some interest from some
private investors
they might not be able to pay as much
but there's some other social housing
providers
and so you're ultimately sort of kind of
giving um
your client okay different sorts of
solutions and
you know you don't know what's going to
stick yeah
but you have to be open right you know
some deals fall out of bed
yeah it happens you know it happens but
i think you just have to trust
the process you know what would be your
advice to somebody because i always say
this is a process you probably heard me
say it's a process not
a journey and if you as you just said if
you follow the process
your success is going to be inevitable
so someone who's watching this is
thinking
i can relate to jay you know um i'm just
getting started
i'm just thinking of getting started
what would your advice be
in their initial few steps to set them
up to win what would you say
um i would say number one
know why you want it yeah because i knew
i wanted it
you know for my wife or my son to you
know so kind of
you know become successful know why
first of all
and write it down yeah so it becomes
clear
and then once you know why you want
something then it's okay you know
how much do i want to make whether it be
free 4k or
have some sort of uh target like that
and then okay how am i gonna get there
will it be
one do i source for myself or two deals
or am i going to get
two rent to rents and then have them
cash flowing
um 800 pounds each yeah but i want to
start
with strategy i'd start much higher yeah
who do i want to be
what do i want to contribute you know
why is it important because i think
you could easily say okay get educated
on youtube
and of course we can get educated or
even take a course
of course we can but unless that's
cemented with a deep desire
you know how to is always going to be
there but do you want to
do you really want to because if you
really want to
you won't give up when you're not making
any money or
when it gets difficult in deep waters or
some kind of say
it's a scam you know which is very easy
to do
so i'd say have that desire to know why
you want it
yeah write it down have an income target
of what you want and then realize how
you can make that
income i know we spoke about the
different routes yeah that's what the
gps
is right find the best route fastest
route
because the gps never ever has ever lied
to you gps
um not not so far no yeah it's always
going to give you the fastest route
right
yeah even me getting here took the gps
there's a couple of country roads and i
was thinking
like but trust the gps it's not it's not
going to lie to you
yeah and in this in i really really
appreciate that that's really good
advice i think
you know i i say this where are you
where do you want to be
and what's the map to get there and
that's what we help people do of course
through our coaching i think one thing
i'll add to that as well is to just take
massive action
yes you know mad one of the things you
the reason you've been successful is
because you take a mad
action there's a lot of talkers out
there yes but there's very few that will
walk the walk
yes and um i'm really really proud so
what's next what's uh what's the plan
over the next
three twelve months um what does your
wife think about all this is she is she
proud of you
i mean she's seen me go into a few
things
yeah so she's happy i've stuck with
something for
uh is it like ten months now yeah
december to why do people flirt around i
see people one minute they're doing
forex then they're doing drop shipping
then they're doing
a bit and i'm just thinking your common
denominator your blueprint is that you
always
flutter around yes i i think they're all
legitimate ways to make money but you
kind of just have to choose one
i love i like property but just choose
one and run with it yeah no of course i
i think you know i've been there i've
been there and it's
you you're looking for the money looking
at the actual
um vehicle rather than looking at how to
drive the vehicle
sure yeah so to speak so so i think
ultimately
um it's just about being completely
aware
of hey you know this suits me
i'm enjoying it run with it yeah you
know so
you're spending more time at home yes is
that nice yeah it's
it's nice and and also another reason
why i love property
there's something for everyone like if
you told me to go straight into rent to
rent
now like doing them i might not enjoy it
i love this
people but some people might like to do
the rental rental service accommodations
or refurb straight away but there's
something
in property for everybody yeah you like
negotiating a property and selling it to
an investor
making some money middle man yeah i love
doing that and i think
in essence marketing and sales like
what a phenomenal like send out 250
letters
yeah only get four responses but maybe
someone might say oh
you know you only got four responses but
if those four responses are people who
want to sell their property
they're people that you didn't know
before before you send out the letters
yeah
and so and i love your letter by the way
the tea bag is a good idea yeah because
ultimately it's a bit different and i've
had people to say look i get 10 letters
a week but
i opened your one because you know i
could see it was a colored letter
and i thought the cup of tea was an
interesting idea so
so yeah i've got something for you
actually can i yeah
so i just written a little something
yeah go for it buddy
until october 2019
before covid i avoided property
saw your youtube videos at a social
media distance
until your crash course broke the
resistance
crash course change course people
learning strong force
property fun and sam talks
first time and i present a deal on stage
first time and i saw everybody engaged
first time and i worked out roi on a
deal
first time and property became real
transformation not just information
phone calls calculations collaborations
dedications
for free what a foundation if you
complain
just jump off a plane thank you
thank you for the eviction challenge you
ask them you want seven grand
to make professional videos i got 10k
subscribers
with just my iphone i wouldn't have
these hmo leads without
leads now rent to rent pays the rent
wife content
because of your content always giving
out your resources
as soon as giving that money like rishi
sunac
haters really jab you uppercut you
each day but you get off the canvas
fight back like aj
[Laughter]
the gift that keeps giving growing
exponentially like a oak tree
keep growing people the fruits never
fall
far from the tree thank you brother i
appreciate that now
so good that's one nice one thank you so
much no
wow well i don't know what to say
i'm speechless i think we need to turn
this into a song or something
get a beat over that dude i appreciate
that that's awesome no one's ever no
one's ever done that before
that's no one's ever done that before
man i appreciate you brother
thank you so much um guys
i think you'll agree jay is an
incredible human i'm touched
and we do this i do this every week you
know every single week i interview
someone on winners on a wednesday
and um you know it's things like this
you know they just just
just give me my mission and
[Music]
drop a nice comment below for jay i'll
get this published
and i'll i'll i'll put the lyrics in the
description or something
if you want to see more videos i don't
know if they'll be as good as that video
but every single week i interview one of
my success students who said their lives
changed their finances revolutionized
through my training in property
you can check a whole we've done over
100 interviews like this over the last
two years
check them out right here you want to
see a video that might help you
check this video out right here and do
me a massive favor and subscribe for
more videos like this and you can do
that
right down here thanks so much guys jay
you're a rockstar nice one
see you next time